okay take me back let's say
hypothetically I'm an independent rapper
I happen to be a drug dealer I got
stupid money money's not a problem right
I'm a rapper in 2004 2005. and I'm like
yo I hit up convict music I'm like I
need the Akon special I need the song I
need the hook I need everything right
what do you hit me upside the head for
200 000. 200 000. now does that increase
if it's a major label it's 200 000 with
this major or not wow 200k the price
didn't change plus you get your Pub oh
yeah I mean you get everything you're
supposed to get that's just for our
services that's amazing 200k you're
doing a lot of those oh we did a lot of
those what was the busiest year you had
the busiest year was oh I mean years the
busiest years was from 2005 to 2009. wow
five good years that's crazy yeah yeah
you had it man did you ever hear that
from radios programmers they complained
everyone I went to I mean I remember
they had created even this I don't know
if it was a law but it was the system it
was whatever you're about to say it was
a real